how did you get involved or just even
interested in the original story and
Debra lips lipsticks book denial the do
not the title of the film is about as
well it were to yeah it's always about
our kids isn't it so long story short my
son was applying to colleges and his his
advisor said to him yeah that's nice
harvard and yale and princeton you might
need a couple other schools and one that
was recommended to him was emory
university I was not familiar with Emory
so hopefully like a good involved parent
i went online and i researched and it
just so happened that on that day they
were announcing a million dollar
endowment to translate deborah lip stats
website about Holocaust denial into
Farsi and Arabic so that people in that
part of the world would have some access
to truth and quite fascinating caused me
to research further read her book and
that led to this particular story yeah
and as we were talking about this one
day I was watching the UN General
Assembly speeches and Men Azad the
President of Iran at the time went on
this rant about the myth of the
Holocaust and I was you know obviously
didn't like hearing that but I also
realized that millions of people were
watching around the world and he was
presenting this is going to sound
familiar he was presenting opinion as
fact and it really or today too that's
what I mean and so that combined with
meeting Deborah's book we realized there
was an opportunity to tell a dramatic
story but also create a film that might
speak to an issue that at the time we
had no idea would be so relevant today
but it is and so did you meet with
Deborah before optioning the book how
that process yeah you know after
starting a conversation in a
relationship with the Dean of the
College of Emory he suggested I think he
took a few days to check us out and make
sure that we were legitimate and she
happened to be coming to Los Angeles and
was at cedars-sinai actually giving a
speech and I was asked to come meet her
there and you know at the time we
weren't sure exactly what it was it
turns out that her book Holocaust on
denial what's the new name of the book
denial Holocaust on trial yes and it
read pretty dramatically to be honest
and it surprised me because usually
you'd think that these would be very
academic dry but the the the the journey
that she was on in addition to obviously
the story it was telling I do believe
that her first question might have been
would Meryl Streep play me yeah she she
talks a little bit about her thought
process because after she met with us
and and knew that it was an opportunity
and by the way participant media was
that was the company we went to we were
in the in production on a film called
the soloist at the time and they came
for a set visit and asked what else we
were interested in and this came up and
they got interested in the project but
Deborah says she spent a couple days
thinking do I want to do this not she
had comfort with us but you know we had
done our job of explaining it could take
a lot of time it's not just about the
book will want to know about you and
about your life and and things that you
haven't written about and she you know
with anybody who gets involved with a
true life story they she she she had to
consider it but fortunately she trusted
us and and we you know I think lived up
to the obligation yeah I think that was
the first time that the ethic that drove
us throughout the entire film came up
was that she said okay I'm gonna I'm
going to agree to this and I'm going to
trust you most important to me her words
tell the truth
just put it out there as fact as truth
don't embellish tell the truth and so
you know what is critical is you know
every word spoken in that courtroom was
spoken in that courtroom sir david hare
who is an incredibly gifted writer was
handcuffed he would only it was his
ethic as well as ours he would only
write fact truth and the actual words
yeah so David took a piece of paper and
put it on the wall in his office the
trial was 32 days he sketched every day
of the trial outlined it talked you know
read through the manuscript of the trial
highlighted what he thought was
important met with each of the
principles who were involved in the
trial got more information about aspects
of it and then you know had to decide
knowing that each scene from the trial
would be exactly from the man use from
the transcript of the trial had to
decide dramatically how to piece them
together so that there was a dramatic
arc to it and challenging so and you're
talking about the writing but also the
directing is pretty impressive to how
could you talk about beginning mixon on
board so about three four years ago we
got a draft of the script that we all
felt was ready to show two directors and
you know as we all do we made our list
and we you know submitted some people
Mick sought us us out his agent called
and said please spend 20 minutes with
him hear him out he's extremely
passionate about this subject and we had
breakfast with him he was really clear
and articulate Mick when he is when he's
focused it's just you can't stop him it
just you sit back and you listen and he
went for about 45 minutes without a
breath I think and and we felt you know
okay he deserves to go in front of the
studio and we and they and he impressed
them as well I think it's fair to say
that a lot of what he talked about
with us in that morning it is in the
film that you just saw I mean he
obviously worked also by the way we you
know then put him and David together and
the collaboration between the two of
them was quite valuable yeah so David is
a great dramatist playwright and
screenwriter Mick had a cinematic vision
for the film he I mean the script was in
in in darn good shape but how do you why
is it a moot is your question why is it
a movie so he spent a lot of time
putting the visual components into the
film and yes it's a courtroom drama and
we know there's restrictions there but
we you know the a schvitz sequence and
trying to figure out how to create some
dynamic to the cinema to the cinema of
the movie and he was really good at his
background is in documentary filmmaking
and he wanted a you know that kind of
feel a raw does Ruth yeah I mean there's
there's a lot of on on set locations
shooting especially you know the London
courthouse it's all location so that's
the real courthouse where the it wasn't
the real one a real okay yeah it's it's
it's a way it was an active go to great
lengths to get a lot of permissions on
this film and the Royal Courts was one
of them even just to be able to shoot
the exteriors where and how we did and
and you know it's three different pieces
that make up that courtroom and by the
way the permission that we had to get
from Auschwitz was not at all easy yes I
want I wanted to ask about that I mean
how does that work for a commercial film
shooting there even one even it wasn't
easy we I mean we spent we made more
trips to Auschwitz which makes I never
would which is I don't you know if you
haven't been there it's it's it's a it's
a awesome and difficult place to go to
but bottom line is this movie was about
truth and we made the case to Auschwitz
that if they didn't in some way work
with us to figure it out then we'd have
to create everything ourselves
wouldn't we then be committing the same
crime that david irving did by you know
by fictionalizing you know the holocaust
thing and they they understood that the
other pressure I know that we felt was
it was also one of the first things Mick
said when he came aboard the picture is
I really want to shoot there I really
need to shoot there and and when Rachel
was coming aboard the picture it's like
well we're really going to shoot at
Auschwitz right they had already said no
to us twice so it was it was a challenge
had a lot of pressure yeah we had a lot
of pressure and you work for the
Holocaust of us survivor did you talk to
any survivors and you obviously to
scholars a lot what was that process
like even with Deborah but talking until
Deborah was our go-to she's one of the
world world's foremost scholars on the
subject to be honest you know yes we
spent time with all the principles but
David hair you know he wanted to hear
from the people that were involved in
the case and he didn't want to hear from
outside he didn't want to be tempted and
so we stayed very disciplined about that
he had extensive meetings I mean I know
I'm switching the subject a little bit
extensive meetings with Richard Rampton
with Anthony Julius and with you know
all of the expertise in the trial just
pages and pages and pages of notes of
you know his interviews with them going
back for a moment though to your
question you know Deborah was hugely
instrumental in us ever succeeding at
Auschwitz as well you know they said no
to even a meeting with us and then she
called and they said okay oh I'll see
you and you know that allowed us to even
get in a room and have the discussion
but she and and she promised them in
that meeting when they film here I
promise you I'll be there and I will
make sure that they do do do it right we
were we there's a perimeter fence around
birkenau and on the other side of the
perimeter fence
it's public they could not stop us in
fact when Steven Spielberg did
Schindler's List he worked outside the
perimeter fence and we were looking for
very specific locations and we found
some areas which are in the film with
them waiting and then him pacing the
fence line but we needed a delousing
chamber and there was a section of the
perimeter fence that went this way then
went this way and the road was out there
but it was a hut on the other side of
that perimeter fence and so from our
point of view it was outside the
perimeter fence and we had a very
intense meeting at its where no no no
and then finally we said but it's
outside the fence look here's the line
ended and the head of Auschwitz is a
fantastic guy Peter Sowinski put his
head in his hand he go fine but don't
ask me for anything else it was a it was
a huge huge win but but flashing forward
you know they have seen the film yeah
they're very proud of the film it was a
a really really wonderful moment to get
their reaction I want to thank you both
for being here and thank you all for
coming thank you thank you